thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so thank you Mr President uh for
continuing this incredible tradition of
inviting the Mayors from the U.S
Conference of Mayors to the White House
it's really an honor I'll tell you as I
walked through this iconic building with
my family I couldn't help but notice the
picture of bipartisan presidents
throughout the years I thought that was
a wonderful Testament to the bipartisan
nature of our organization of the U.S
Conference of Mayors and it was reminded
me of a story that my dad on stole
said that a particularly difficult
moment in Lyndon Johnson's presidency
they said to him you know Mr President
can it get any worse
he sort of thought about it you pause
and said oh sure I could be a mayor
so so thank you so much Mr President Mr
President honorable members and fellow
Mayors uh America's Mayors stand on the
front lines of American democracy
we serve the American people every day
from every background and in every part
of the country
we listen and Lead
We Serve and Protect
and we deliver for everyone
while we hold different viewpoints
philosophies and experiences
today we all carry a common message
our federal government should act and we
need it to act as quickly
it needs to address the particles of
America
to find a solution to the humanitarian
and security crisis on our border
this means addressing the core drivers
not just the symptoms
of this crisis
from our confronting the repressive
regimes of Latin America to the human
trafficking cartels we must not
and we also must act on modernizing our
Visa system and our dysfunctional
immigration laws
and I was pleased to see you Mr
President begin to address address these
issues recently when you visited the
Border
but of course
of course we all know we have a long way
to go
we also need to act on public safety we
from the federal government to the local
government
need to clearly support our police you
said that just a year ago in our
conference
we must bring the defund police movement
to an end in word and indeed
we must support
we know the president is committed to
funding law enforcement and for that we
are grateful
we also must revisit failed policies
like no cash bail which seem to be
contributing to the spike in violent
crime in our cities
we need to act on maintaining our fiscal
health and economic security all of us
here must balance our budget
and honor our debts
the federal government must do the same
just as Mayors have done across America
finally
we should continue working together in
the spirit of the bipartisan
infrastructure law by further building
out our American infrastructure from
roads and bridges to our digital economy
we share your concerns about
strengthening our infrastructure and our
security
we need to do more we want to do more
and God willing we will do more together
to strengthen America and keep
mature strong
thank you for your time
and thank you again for hosting us today
in the White House
and now I'd like to introduce the second
vice president of the conference Andy
Ginther the Mayor of Columbus Ohio
Heartland of the country to share a few
remarks on how our partnership with the
administration is rebuilding American
Manufacturing
and strengthening the nation's economy
thank you
[Music]
thank you President Suarez vice
president chivi all of our colleagues
here today as President Suarez mentioned
I'm able to get the mayor of the city of
Columbus and part of the leadership team
at the U.S conference Mayors I have the
pleasure this afternoon of introducing
someone who has been an incredible
friend
our strongest Ally
as America's mayors
with this President think about this
just two years ago
Mr President entered office American
cities were hurting
we were still trying to make our way
through the most disruptive Global event
in any of our lifetimes
Mayors were on the front lines of the
pandemic and all the downstream
consequences
economic disruption mental illness gun
violence homelessness
we got to work and so did this president
he said we're not just going to build
back
[Applause]
he said we're not just going to build
back
we're going to build back that
and working hand in hand with local
leaders he has delivered over and over
and over again
[Music]
our CEO and executive director Tom
Cochran has been at the Helm of the
conference of Mayors for more than 50
years
I know he agrees when I say the last two
years have been the most consequential
and productive for Mayors in the history
of the U.S conference
[Applause]
[Music]
so much of that is thanks to our
partnership with President Biden the
American Rescue plan ensured we could
protect Public Health keep city workers
on the job and keep our local economies
afloat
the bipartisan infrastructure law
allowing us not to just catch up on
years to neglect but jump ahead and
claim the future
beat out the rest of the world so we
have the most efficient and safe
transportation system for the 21st
century
the inflation reduction act delivers on
one of the mayor's biggest priorities
fighting back against climate change
the gone safety legislation shows that
fighting back against gun violence is
possible
we have more to do
but we do not accept
the deaths from gun violence in our
communities are just an acceptable part
of Living in America the first time
the first time since Clinton
administration
bipartisan gun safety legislation is now
the law of the land because of this
President it's something incredibly
important to my community in our part of
Ohio the chips and science Act
will ensure that the United States not
China
is leading the development of new
technology it has the potential to turn
the old Rust Belt
the new Silicon Valley
not bad for two years of working
look we're a bipartisan group Mayors
don't let politics or partisanship give
the way of getting things done for the
people we serve former mayor of
Pittsburgh used to say there are three
kinds of people in America
Republicans Democrats and mayors
[Applause]
[Music]
someone says it can't be done we just
work harder I can't tell you how
refreshing it is to have a president who
works like mayors
I know he'll be the first to tell you
we've got a lot more work to do and we
need to do it together
but I think it's worth taking a moment
to appreciate
far we have come
all that we've accomplished together
America can still do great things
with Republicans Democrats and
independents come together to fight for
America
Mr President thank you for your
leadership your partnership and most
importantly your friendship with
America's mayors
friends it is a great privilege and
honor
for this little kid from Columbus to
introduce the 46th president of the
United States America's greatest
champion of Mayors President Joe Biden
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
you don't want this going to my head
from Scranton
look uh
[Music]
mayor Suarez uh thank you for your
leadership for the conference excuse me
I got a little frog in my throat but uh
and Andy thank you for that introduction
you know
it's wonderful to finally welcome all to
the White House after not being able to
be here because the pandemic for so long
we appreciated a great deal and uh some
of you know I started my career as a
county councilman
in the state of Delaware and uh and then
I ran through the U.S Senate because
serving as local official was too hard
they know where you live
I knock on your door and
I've always had enormous respect for the
job you do
by the way as far as you and I have
something else in common you know what
it is
we both married way above our station
you all think I'm kidding something's
just self-edited
today
is two years since I was sworn in as
president
[Applause]
we need help
keep your health we've gotten a lot done
I think if you look around the room we
got a lot of cabinet members who are
mayors
a lot of Mayor
we got a little Mitchell Andrew from New
Orleans down there you know
that's like being mayor of a country
yeah I tell you what my daughter went
down to Tulane University in large
apartment because his dad his long story
but uh when he was mayor and uh I
thought she's going to come home talk
with the boy talking funny at me you
know what I mean it's a bottle of foods
or something man
but uh and uh mayor Pete as uh
let's call the mayor Pete
we got uh Marty Wiles from Boston
we got a lot of bears a lot of mirrors
and that's why I think we're making such
progress look um the fact is that um
you know I was as fitting that we are
here together today and because your
marriage know how to get things done and
that's not hyperbole it's a fact because
you have no choice as a matter of fact
yesterday I was in California we're
grappling with historic California
started off for governor looked at me
said Mr President we used to be the
fifth largest world number the fourth uh
that's true in the world
I tell you what so I genuflect it and we
moved out
I said that means you don't need that 10
billion dollars we just did right
you don't think I'm kidding that's what
we did
well our kid decided he's a great
governor and is great well but look
dealing with historic storms and
flooding you know when your town or city
uh faced the crisis if the mayor gets
the first call
and I've seen it I've traveled this
country after floods and tornadoes
wildfires hurricanes as a matter of fact
I was kidding but it was a serious piece
to it when I pointed out that to to the
governor we've got to stay stop taking
these helicopter rides because I went
over this I think was a fifth one in
this state travel in the state more of
the of the force was burned down they
grew up into Oregon then the entire
state of of Missouri I mean it's a long
long long way a lot of damage and I want
to thank the Mayors across the country
for doing everything everything they can
to recover and rebuild it matters that
the ones who you're the ones that make
uh sure is as straight as it sounds the
garbage gets picked up the potholes gets
fixes the buses that you can catch to
work and be able to continue to be there
on time and so much more of a
significant consequence but those things
are consequential
you affect people's quality of life more
than any other group of people in the
world and Mayors know the measure of
successes and how many partisan points
you score it's how many how many
problems you fix
can you fix the problem
when I came to office
can you hear me
the pandemic was raging our economy was
reeling but we acted together
now two years in is clearer than ever
that our plan is working we're building
the economy from the bottom up in the
middle out not just the top down because
when we do that by the way the wealthy
do very very well and everybody the poor
have a shot in the middle class can have
a little breathing room
an economy that benefits that folks in
the Heartland as well as in our cities
and all across America and uh you know I
remember uh you know as I said my my
family when I was born in Scranton
Pennsylvania when coal died when I was
in third grade we had a mood but I go
back to Scranton everybody's a joke is
they're from Scranton and what is from
Scranton but think of all the towns you
know and some of you are married that
they go through school they want to stay
where their family is where their
relatives are whether they know
everything and then have to say mama
gotta leave there's no jobs here there's
no jobs here in my town I'm serious I'm
deadly earnest
and what we're trying to do is not just
rebuild the economy bring back the pride
pride and the sense of belonging the
sense of I want to stay where I live
Where I Live Now where I'm able to do
what I want to do
and that's the whole purpose we're
trying to do in our cities where people
used to move out but you know now
they're beginning to move back in as
soon as you're growing not just big
cities small towns as well the economy
rewards work where we don't need a
college degree to provide for your
family it helps to have that college
degree but you don't need it to provide
for your family
two years ago this week 18 million
people were out of work two years ago
this week now the nut number is under
1.6 million you're the lowest level
[Applause]
[Music]
s has been in 50 years we've created 11
million jobs 750
000 manufacturing jobs where in the hell
is it written to say we can't be in the
manufacturing capital of the world
okay
I got so sick and tired of us exporting
jobs and importing product we're now
importing jobs and exporting product
s
because we begin to invest in ourselves
again because of you all
over the last two years more Americans
applied to start a small business in any
year in history and a year on record
that make up 50 percent of all the
economy in America
fewer families are facing foreclosure or
an eviction before than before the
pandemic families in our communities are
starting to breathe it's a little bit
easier but folks it's not only that
pride is coming back to American
communities and to American cities and
that's not just on the coast as I said
it's in every part of the country
including many towns and cities and
local communities that have been
forgotten for much too long much too
long it's not an accident it's a
strategy that when I came to office a
strategy that we stuck to even in the
face of a lot of criticism a strategy
that we put in an accident strategy to
recover and rebuild and invest in
America
you know hesitate a second to just
address a little bit we used to invest
two percent of our GDP in research and
development every year that's what we
did in America
but then a long way we stopped
we stopped investing in America and
research and development we invest now
seven tenths of one percent
we used to be number one not China is
number two we're number eight I mean
things we've allowed to happen it's not
been conscious
just sort of slipped up on us we just
and the way in which we've changed the
way we dealt with corporate law a whole
range of things
but we're changing it we're changing it
as I said we're going to export product
not jobs with your support I signed the
law the American Rescue plan deliver
immediate economic relief to families
and communities that need it most one
study found that before the law was
passed
70 percent of the Mayors in America
expected to cut critical jobs like
teachers and Transit workers 27 percent
of you were facing steep cuts of police
department budgets
so we acted
and with the cares act we passed under
the previous administration someone had
to go to your you had to go to your
legislatures for permission to get the
money I've been the bad guy when I was a
Senator and as vice president of pain in
the neck why do you have to go through
the legislature
no no I'm serious I'm deadly Earnest
about that
because you go through the legislature
you can't blame that and they say I want
a piece of my district
but you can apply directly
often I wrote the cops Bill years ago
you didn't have to legislature Governor
you could apply directly if you're
qualified you got it directly you got
the money directly well that's what I'm
talking about
she's barely make sure the American
Rescue plan empowered you directly
directly to avoid painful layoffs you
put cops back in the street firefighters
back in the jobs you kept teachers in
classrooms you asked for the money and
you qualified for it and Knoxville
Tennessee American Cannon gave premium
pay as mayor here
there you are mayor well you gave
premium pay to police officer and
firefighters to keep them on the job it
was a big deal
in mesh Arizona mayor Giles I don't know
where the mayor's here I got to get
people in trouble calling this out
Mr Mayor how are you
I bought five new ambulances hired
Behavioral Health clinicians to help the
fire department of Crisis calls
and by the way you know when a cop
starts up in a domestic violence case or
someone's on a stand on edge of a bridge
they don't need a cop they need a
psychiat a psychologist with them I
should ever put more people no I'm
serious we're beginning to understand
this all again
and a lot of you are applying for the
money and using it for these mental
health issues as well
you know there are countless examples
when it comes to Public Safety when it
come to Public Safety we know the answer
is not to defund the police
[Applause]
Mr retrain some police
is to make sure there's accountability
so make sure we know exactly what's
happened but it's not to defund the
police they need more funding and they
need ancillary help as well
[Applause]
350 billion dollars of state and local
governments and we urge them to make was
available to them to make communities
safer it turned out that one of the
largest investments in public safety
ever and every single Republican in
Congress voted against it but a lot of
remayers said you talked to your
representatives said whoa what that you
know and maybe Biden's idea but not at
all his ideas are bad
have made major investments in community
violence intervention initiatives these
Studies have shown in some cases they
can reduce violent crime up to 60
particularly among our youth doesn't
always do that much but it can do that
that much
but as you may or know better than most
when you see these problems of crime and
the opioid epidemic you know the big
part of that is mental health mental
health I want to take a moment to talk
to you about how we're addressing that
as well
by the way bevec Murphy the Surgeon
General has been really focusing on this
great deal a lot of you have worked with
him
through the American Rescue plan we
provided initial funding for cities to
start to address some of the mental
health and needs arising from the
pandemic five billion dollars for States
and Community organizations deliver
mental health and substance abuse
treatment
103 million dollars in funding
specifically addressed Mental Health on
front for front line health
professionals
like nurses you ready in your
communities you've dealt with your
hospitals where the nurses are just
overworked and have been serious serious
problems in terms of their own Mental
Health
we know it wasn't enough to find the
bipartisan safer communities Act and we
went even further that provides 10
billion dollars in just mental health
needs 2 billion of that it's for young
people in particular to pay for things
like school counselors and we know what
fentanyl is doing to families and
communities all across the country
we work talk to make sure the First
Responders have what they need when they
respond to overdoses for young people
are dying and by the way we've
confiscated enormous enormous amount of
fentanyl not just at the border but
beyond the Border we've confiscated
throughout I think it's let me get the
number here I don't want to get it wrong
we've confiscated 379 million doses of
Fentanyl
from the other way
hundred thousand most of the kids have
died from
and has put in things that they never
anticipate as part of
as marriage you know how much this
matters that's why I brought many former
mayors in the administration
Lance bottoms is here
[Music]
in Maryland than being president but I
don't know
the moment only kidding but all kid
decide well whatever she's a senior
advisor on public engagement led the
cities through the pandemic she makes
sure to bring the prospective local
officials and Community leaders the
decisions we make here at the White
House secretary agriculture Tom vilsack
a former mayor in Iowa
strengthening our nation's rural
communities and he really is he's a
smart smart guy he knows what he's doing
and he I know he's a secretary of
agriculture for what he's doing American
grocery stores or Stockwell American
farmers Thrive and our young people have
access to food when schools are closed
Secretary of Housing Urban Affairs
Marsha floods Marsha is right here she
got a hell of a job
[Applause]
[Music]
working very working very hard to close
the wealth Gap expanding efforts to
build generational welfare home
ownership how did all all the mainstream
middle class people get their wealth
90 of through investing in their homes
they were able to buy
home that's how they're able to bar to
get their kids to school that's how they
built
happening now and she's working really
hard to provide that opportunity and as
well as combating homelessness which a
lot of you are dealing with on your
streets
and while folks continue to recover
we're also rebuilding Mitch Landry the
former mayor of New Orleans was
president of this organization is now my
senior advisor in infrastructure
coordinator to help me rebuild America
through a once in a generation
bipartisan infrastructure bill it's
always hard
[Music]
to modernize our nation's roads highways
Bridges railroads airports ports Water
Systems the the internet and so much
more last year alone nearly 7 000
projects were identified and are
underway with funding from the
infrastructure law by the end of this
year that will be more than twenty
thousand more than twenty thousand if I
can hit again for a second aggress
slightly one of the things I've been
telling the press that they look at me
like they look at me like I'm wonderful
right no okay now all can decide why I
keep saying it
we did a lot last year with your help
it's only now beginning to bear fruit
because we pass this infrastructure bill
that's a 10-year bill and it's taking
time to get it off the ground
Mitch McConnell and I just announced
that for the construction of a new
bridge a billion dollars across the Ohio
River it's going to fundamentally change
Transportation North and South not just
from Ohio to Kentucky but across Across
the Nation
so many things are happening we passed
the bill relating to the cost of of
insulin well guess what only now as of
January 1st a lot of people are waking
up and finding out if our Medicare they
only have to pay 35 bucks a month
around
the country to be able to make money but
I tell you I
people explained when they raise the
price that is beyond inflation that
they've invested more money in what they
did in order to justify the price
otherwise guess what we're going to go
and move along no I'm serious I'm
serious we're so we're doing things that
just make some common sense
there's some common sense because you
know labor secretary Marty walls former
mayor of Boston
but he's making sure these projects have
prevailing ways and purported and
purporting to move and suggest for
significant apprenticeship so people can
make a living off of what they're doing
and by the way I'm going to talk on a
minute about
dealing with the whole idea of what
we're doing in terms of new Investments
and the chip legislation for one of the
leading investors of over
I think is so far 22 billion dollars in
the United States from another country I
said why are you investing in America he
said because you've got the best workers
and you're the safest environment in the
world in which we can do this
so we're helping to rebuild our economy
with jobs that don't require four-year
degrees promoting an economy that works
for middle class and working class
Americans Transportation Secretary of
Peace here look we know
the better known as Merit paid but
many of you to address those quality of
life issues that really matter to people
you serve not just through big Bridges
and Highway projects but through those
are important but also through smaller
projects that are critical in your
cities
like in Madison Wisconsin where mayor
Rose Conway was buying 46 electric buses
replacing those dirty diesels bad for
the health of the environment making it
clear no I'm serious it's a big deal
we're open City rebuild Airport
there you are okay
well thank you
and it means our kids aren't going to be
inhaling that diesel fumes when they get
off the boat for real it matters
environmentally it matters as well and
so you know we're helping cities rebuild
airport terminals in Atlanta with mayor
Andre Dickens and Orlando with mayor
buddy Dyer in LA with Karen bass and
with the leadership of Vice President
Harris we're partnering with you to
deliver affordable high-speed internet
to every single household in America
affordable high-speed internet
so no parent has to park in front of
McDonald's when to do the homework for
their kids when they're on when when the
school's not in session where they can't
go to school
it's a big deal it's a big deal for
Farmers I'm mad at and a whole lot of
other people to know exactly what
products are costing
and sell them for it and now we're 50
million households have affordable
internet that they didn't have just well
before we pass the law we're also making
the biggest investment ever ever in
climate the inflation reduction
[Music]
foreign
millions of good paying jobs and
investing in fence line communities that
have suffered the most as a consequence
of being smothered by pollution
think of the cancer alley in Louisiana
or Route 9 in Delaware where all those
facilities are but we made a commitment
we're going to invest first and foremost
as we clean up those communities
and we're going to invest in that make
that Community better again
our economic agenda United a
manufacturing boom the semiconductor
Boom the battery Boom the electric
vehicle Boom for making things in
America again in every part of America
cities large and small
the mayor of Phoenix Kate is Kate here
thank you
I was with her last month to announce a
small investment 40 billion dollars
40 billion dollars invested by TSC
tmsc the two semiconductor factors in
thousands of union workers helping to
build them
and Andy you know I the Field of Dreams
outside of Columbus where Intel's
investing it's 100 acres but they're
investing 20 billion dollars to expand
semiconductor manufacturing I said 100 a
thousand acres I thought that I didn't
mean no you shouldn't have but I said
this is the Field of Dreams it is
a Field of Dreams and by the way of
those jobs about of the twelve thousand
jobs seven thousand are construction
jobs but guess what they're paying
prevailing wage
and those 5 000 jobs left the average
salary at those places they tell them
are going to be 123 000 bucks a year and
you don't need a college degree
[Applause]
this is important
urged by all of you it's happy to know
small because small parking is a
bipartisan ships and science Act
everybody if I signed on the folks have
joined me at the bill signing at other
victories with your support so many of
you sign the first we've signed the
first major gun legislation in 30 years
I'll say
what I've said before not only in
agreement but we're going to ban assault
weapons we're going to do it again
[Music]
on Sunday we acknowledge what would have
been the 50th anniversary of Roe v Wade
we're continuing to fight and protect
women's right to choose last year
and last year when I held the first of
its kind White House Summit at the
request of others against hate fuel
violence this group led the effort with
115 Mayors to sign a compact Democratic
Republic is Independents to prevent and
address this type of violence in our
communities
committed to continue this work with all
of you but I need you badly but there's
more to do
as is mentioned by the by your president
immigration is another major issue
affecting many of your communities
particularly the Border communities of
nearsight and their communities
I visited the Border early this month
the first time as president I bet before
for the first time as president I'm
taking action where I have the legal
capacity to do so
I'll continue to call on Congress to act
to pass comprehensive immigration reform
fix the system
[Music]
the first bill I introduced was a
comprehensive reform legislation on
immigration
but
because of some in the Congress they
refused to consider it they found a
better issue to campaign on than an
issue to solve so we have a choice they
keep using immigration to try to score
political points or we can help solve
the problem
immigration reform used to be a
bipartisan issue and we can make it that
again in my view let me close with this
I ran for office for three reasons one
was and I was even my campaign team
thought I was wrong in terms of what I'm
based on which I was wrong
one of the things after you know I when
I got elected as a 29 year old kid to
the senate had to wait to be legally be
to be able to be sworn in because I
wasn't old enough
no no joke I uh you know I was uh they
talked about you know am I being the you
know the youngest I wasn't there was one
younger elected popularly than I was but
you know I I spent a lot of time
um
I used to get asked all the time Mr
Mayor what's the secret because if I won
against a really good guy who's a decent
man we never had a crossword with us
aggressive Republican who helped write
the clean water and Clean Air actress
the disagreements on a number of other
things
and second time Iran he actually
endorsed me but the point is this is
it's simple
I used to get asked what's it must be a
secret if you could have won there must
be some Secret
and I used to think about it that people
for the next three four years that asked
me that who are running for office in
Delaware
and I finally figured it out and you all
are successful and you know it I said
the secret is have you figured out
what's worth losing over
have you figured out what's so important
to you you'd rather lose than win and
have to compromise on it
and so when I ran this time and I had
not planned on running again
why the hell didn't you follow your
instinct
but I honestly God did my son passed
away and I had no desire to I was a
professor at the University of
Pennsylvania and things were going fine
make a long story short when I did I
decided there were three reasons to run
and I mean it one was to restore the
soul of America
decency honor the idea
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the way and I've been this way my whole
career how we build the economy
from the bottom up in the middle of for
real
I I look I come from a state of
corporate America more corporations are
Incorporated in my state than every
other one of your States combined
combined and I got elected seven times
there so you know I wasn't I was
anti-corporate but I have a different
view in terms of what the priority
should be
and so as I said when the middle does
well they generate hope give chance to
the work of class and when they do well
the wealthy do very very well
the third reason I ran which has been
turned out to be the hardest to deal
with that's unite the country
we are a democracy
we cannot be sustained if we stay 50
different Islands or two different
parties that no longer talk to one
another
the last two years since my inauguration
I think we've made some progress large
part because of many of you sitting in
this room
and I'm really optimistic in the year
ahead that we're implementing the laws
we've already passed will deliver real
benefits the people are going to feel
them in their everyday lives
now that work we're going to continue to
do together together we're proving that
every city and town is country
our best days are ahead of us not behind
us and I really mean it I was asked by
my senior team Peter remember said if I
could do anything to change the attitude
of optimism in America what was the one
thing I'd do just I could change one
thing
it's going to sound bizarre when I tell
you I said I have cure cancer
and they looked at me like the church
because nobody thinks it's this from
frightening thing to people
and if we did it America could do big
things again there's nothing beyond our
capacity I swear to God there is nothing
beyond the capacity States of America
remember who in hell we are we're the
United States of America we work
together
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so I
that we will take from a couple of
Mayors we'll start with mayor Tashara
Jones from St Louis Missouri
good afternoon Mr President
how are you great great thanks to the
bipartisan infrastructure law and the
chips and science act we're seeing jobs
return to our cities and we're preparing
our citizens for the many opportunities
to come what can we as Mayors do to help
you further your agenda of Shoring up
our national security
and bring more high quality jobs to
America cities
I think two things one
be realistic and don't confuse
the national debt with
with debt reduction on a yearly basis
the debt we're paying on and we're going
to have a little discussion about that
with uh
the new majority leader of the House
has accumulated over 200 years
over 200 years not a joke
that's how long that's what that's what
the national debt is it's over you know
31 trillion dollars but it's over 200
years
and one quarter of that debt one quarter
event that was accumulated in the four
years of my predecessor
one quarter of them
so what we've actually done mayor we've
actually cut the deficit on a yearly
basis in the first year because of what
you now I'm not being solicited because
we all did
350 billion dollars and last year this
year we cut that deficit on a yearly
basis for over a trillion dollars so
it's over a trillion roughly 400 billion
dollars we've cut the deficit
the yearly depth of the year to year we
got to focus on making sure we do not
accumulate more debt on the historic 200
years and gradually continue to reduce
it one of the things that we've done is
the the budget we're going to be
introducing you're all going to see is
expected to reduce the debt another
trillion dollars this next year
by spending more spending less than we
than we then we spending less than we
bring in
now the big debate let me be honest with
you and I'm going to talk about the
State of the Union there's a fundamental
disagreement on what we should do to cut
what what do we cut well it's not just
cutting what do you raise what taxes do
people pay how do they pay their taxes
and do they pay it fairly and so one of
the things that's going to be a big
issue in dealing with the national debt
that could if we don't meet our national
debt and renege in the first time we
have a Calamity that exceeds anything
that's ever happened in finance in the
United States and so one of the things
that we're going to do is it's going to
get down to a decision of whether do we
in fact make sure that folks
do we cut Social Security to raise taxes
on trillionaires
I mean billionaires
there's
745 or 50 billionaires in America
average tax rate they pay is 2 percent I
think you should be able to be a
billionaire but I think you should pay a
little more than two percent
no no I I am
[Applause]
not trying to murder the Douglas knows
me well I'm not trying to be alarming
about it but I mean it's a reality the
argument there's a lot of arguments why
that shouldn't be because they generate
so much energy and so much growth Etc
but there's a lot of things we can do
now the option of this being going to be
offered you're going to see is they want
to the way to deal with cutting that
debt is to cut Social Security cut
Medicaid we got to do something about
social security man no but but this is
these are the kind of debates we're
going to have
and they're going to be honest debates
for you it seems to me for a mayor the
things that I believe and I've not been
a mayor but I think I've watched long
enough to know the way the difference
between Craig was like you and folks who
don't do much
or don't I should say
she said you've had more difficulty is
focus on the things that make your city
unique and make it grow
one of the things that make it grow well
first of all
and I mean I'm I could go on but I'm
just going to give you one example
we're in a situation where if you were a
one of the reasons why America became
the most advanced and economically
prosperous nation in the 21st century
we're the first nation in the world to
have Universal education system
okay grades one through twelve
now others had systems that were
Superior to ours in terms of their
exclusiveness but not Universal
now I wonder if anybody today we're
starting off and saying you know we're
going to decide we decide we're going to
have to have a universal education
would anybody think in the second
quarter of the 21st Century
that 12 years was enough to compete
I don't think so for I mean for for real
so a lot of you are doing a lot of
experimental work in terms of not just
Pre-K but you're doing in terms of
Education teaching kids to read write
add and subtract and three and four and
five years old and not and you're
focusing on Apprentice programs after
after college you're focusing on I mean
After High School you're focusing in
high school and allowing people to learn
trades instead of remember there used to
be even even you're old enough to
remember they're not you mayor
[Applause]
but when you know there are shop classes
in school where people learned whether
they could they're comfortable working
with their hands whether they so there's
a lot of things that we can do in
education
there's a lot of things you can also do
in terms of dealing with
I'm going to get you a lot more money
God willing because I think we have
Universal support for it beyond the
money it came out of the original
legislation there's a proposal that I've
just presented to I'm the guy that wrote
the community policing law but got very
bad publicity but guess what people are
figuring out guess what it works the
people who most need the help the most
victimized of the poorest communities
so we need cops in those communities
from those communities but cops that are
held accountable to everything that they
say we're supposed to do
and we can do that so focusing on law
enforcement that in fact is Equitable
focusing on you know for example
nationally I still think we should have
the George Floyd legislation but I
didn't have an episode what I was able
to do I said no knock warrants or
limited significantly we're in a
situation where you have to no choke
holes or certain basic things
you know when I was coming up as a kid
you know cops were learned to you know
required to learn to shoot to kill well
you ought to be able to shoot to stop
you know everything shouldn't be an
extreme so the way we train police
officers is changing and there's a lot
of things you can look at to determine
whether or not you can affect the safety
of your city
and uh and also I think that well I'm
not going to go out but so there's a lot
of things you can do
because I believe you'll have the
economic wherewithal
through the programs and the federal
government not telling you what to do
but giving you the wherewithal to do the
things that you think most need to be
done
and every Community is a slightly
different need a slightly different need
in terms of emphasis and uh you know I
think one of the great Mayors in the
country is Duggan from Detroit not a
joke I got a house
and I remember Barack Obama turned me
one day and said not not a joke Joe
fixed Detroit I said oh no problem
no problem
well I got to know Detroit I found out
things that mayor taught me was guess
what that something was as close to 70
percent of the people in the 60 of the
people in the city who were high school
educated had jobs that were outside the
city
and we couldn't get there they didn't
have 60 didn't have cars
so we ended up getting what 20 new buses
was it initially I mean you know just
practical things to determine what are
the things that both allow neighborhoods
to stay United and move and again
there's a lot and one of the things that
that mayor Landru has I still call him
the mayor but much more than that he uh
he's running this show for me because we
also have I can't remember the I asked
for the phone number and I forgot it
881-8946 that you can call because we
have people in here no no I'm not joking
a lot of people know we have these
programs but they're hard to navigate
so you can pick up the phone and call
how do I get the money to do A B C or D
can I do this with that to cut through
the red tape
anyway
you're about to cut me off
thank you Mr President
um we do have one more question
um from mayor shivi from Reno Nevada
[Applause]
for inviting us to your home we love
what you've done with the place
and also I want to say thank you museums
right
um I want to say thank you from the
bottom of all of our hearts I know
everyone in the room is so grateful that
you have brought Mayors into your
cabinet I think it should be a
requirement of every president
foreign
[Applause]
so you talked a little bit about mental
health and I wanted to say thank you so
much for your leadership on that it
means the world to me we are so
fortunate to work with your Surgeon
General he is fantastic
so all your Mayors in the room are going
to become mental health Warriors and
we're going to be addressing addiction
and loss and grief I'm going to ask you
something very personal you've had a lot
of loss and grief in your life and I
know over the last few years a lot of
Americans have had a loss a lot of loss
in grief because of the pandemic what
would be your
what would what would you say to them
and your advice to someone experiencing
personal loss and greed well first of
all
as close staff knows I spend a lot of
time
with folks who've gone through walls
wife daughter pregnant children
Etc
and granted I did lose
my wife and daughter right after I got
elected to the Senate
tractor trailer broadsided and killed my
wife and daughter and my
two boys were little boys they were
on top of their
deceased mom and sister for a long while
because of the
local fire department a long time during
the jaws of life to get them out
and then I
a guy who should be standing there was
anybody who's going to be president and
I'm not just not high privilege my son
Beau he's more qualified than I always
and uh and uh but he
he uh decided I'll never forget and
asked me one Friday he said dad what are
you doing on Friday and I said what do
you need he said I'd like you to swear
me in I said swear you in your attorney
general State adult I swear into what he
said I joined the United States National
Guard the Delaware National Guard
and then when they his unit got sent he
didn't have to go but he got
exemption to go as long as he gave up
the seat
and uh you know that was a
tough
but you know what I had family
I had an incredible wife
no man deserves one great love let alone
two
and I had a a mom and a dad and a sister
and a brother
were alive and um
and for example when I when the accident
happened early on my sisters my best
friend in the world gave up her home and
she and her husband moved into my house
tell me raise my kids without me and I
just moved in
and
by the way five days after I was married
they were gone
but I say that not about me but it's
about
what mental health does I had people
around me
that were there to help me I was lucky
I used to everybody thinks I commuted
every day for I've traveled over a
million two hundred thousand miles on
Amtrak not a joke I committed every
single day for 36 years and then beyond
that it was vice president
to go home everybody thought they got
one home because
I went home I couldn't afford two places
but right now I I went home because I
get to you know kiss my boys good night
and lay down with Sarah prayers and then
my daughter Etc but I had my mother
I had my mother there every morning I
dropped the boys off and they were
little in my mom's house and then later
I'd be able to drive him to school and
I'd be picked up but my point is I had
so much help
and I had psychological help everyone
down there was someone there to us
basically hold my hand well that's the
mental health
that a lot of families don't have
they don't have
and a lot of and a lot of folks are
a situation where if they just had
somebody to talk to
they just had and that's why I think
some of the things we can do that can
also help families gone through some
real the difficult times is for example
preschool education age three that does
two things it helps your kid get an
advantage but it also helps mom or dad
or a single parent or parents are going
through hell to have somebody there
until five o'clock taking care of your
kid father while they're learning
so there's a lot of things that it does
that gives people but in addition to
that
people who've gone through really tough
times with drug addiction and a whole
range of other things alcoholism
they also are in a situation where they
find themselves being able to uh have
the kind of medical help that is needed
in the mental health side of it
and so
I I just think
having people to reach out who are
professionals who know how to deal with
people going through trauma tragedy or
or self-inflicted wounds that they've
had
and uh and I and it makes a gigantic
difference
the need for I mean look at what's
happened
and I think we I sometimes underestimate
it because I stopped thinking about it
but I'm sure you don't
we lost one over one million people
in several years to covet
what that means is
and the study was done that there are
eight people close to every one of those
on average those one million people
how many mothers fathers brothers
sisters Uncle aunts got up in the
mornings and or sat down for dinner at
night and there was an empty chair
how many
and what impact does that have on the
rest of the family
and there's a lot of tricks that you can
be taught a lot of things you can do to
engage the children who survive engage
the children who aren't addicted James a
parent so I just think there's so many
things that you can do and the reason I
gave you my personal story was I think
it's just about knowing somebody's there
knowing somebody can reach out to when
you get scared and hold their hand
whether it's a drug problem whether it's
a physical problem whether it's just a
and by the way
my wife Jill got very engaged with uh
the uh the Brits and the and the U.S and
the military and dealing with trying to
convince people think of the military
the one thing you're taught to as a as a
as a warrior is never complained never
explained man don't complain
well guess what
mental health is a problem
it's a serious problem
you have more people dying of suicide in
the United States military than any
other reason today
more people
and so we got involved in reaching out
to help families so that you don't make
it and then I'll conclude with this
we have to take the stigma off of Mental
Health
mental health is no different than you
break your arm or your leg
I know it really isn't it's a God's
truth it is a problem that is a medical
problem
and so hardest part is to get people a
lot of people
I say most people to say to acknowledge
that I'm getting help
I'm getting help that's why we had this
effort to deal my wife deal with this
program to provide for health for you
know
post-traumatic stress for so many
so many warriors
man you were there you see all the
people I don't know how many people
that you just that need the help
but they it's a help that you need any
more than you need if you broke your leg
but we've got to take the stigma away
stigma away from the notion that you
need mental health
because it's no different and by the way
think of this
how many folks do you know how many cops
on your department
need some mental health because they're
suffering from post-traumatic stress
what they went through
I mean we we don't look at them and say
you know they're weak
but you know it's just about
anyway we just got to reach out and
change the notion of a stigma associated
with an ocean of seeking mental health
and it starts early when you can detect
with children that need some guidance
really or doesn't mean they're quote
crazy
means they have some disposition that
has to be treated
and there's a lot that can be done I'm
talking too much I apologize guys thank
you all very much
the state was guests please remain in
your speech by the president
[Music]